We're all made of matter, right? You, me, that
very tall building. But what about its evil
twin antimatter? Wait does that mean there's an
antimatter Rad out there somewhere? [evil noises]
I've got a physicist in an elevator
ready to explain antimatter to me in
the time it takes to go up and down that
building. [Music] Hey Ciaran. Hey Rad.
Let's go. What is antimatter? All right,
antimatter is all about particles and
anti-particles. So particles of matter, the stuff
that you and me are made of, protons, electrons,
things like this. But every particle in nature has
kind of like an evil twin, a particle which is the
same in every way except it has the opposite
electric charge and they annihilate when they
meet. What do you mean annihilate? So you get
a particle and an antiparticle, when they meet
they cause a big explosion and all of their mass
gets turned into pure energy. I thought matter
couldn't be created or destroyed though? Matter
can be created and destroyed but only in equal
amounts of matter and antimatter at the same time.
Okay I'll just accept that. Yeah. So this is just
a theory? We've never found antimatter? Absolutely
not, we're showered by antiparticles all the time
from outer space. These things called cosmic
rays. We use antiparticles in medical imaging,
PET scans. Okay we're halfway through. That was
very very quick. They put some kind of material,
a radioactive material, which is spewing out
antimatter. When it meets the normal matter
in your body it makes photons and then you can
image the the soft tissue in your body. How are we
putting antimatter into our bodies? Wouldn't that
just explode? It does explode and that's how we
image the workings of the organs. That sounds bad!
This is the defining characteristic of antimatter.
If you get a particle and an antiparticle and
they meet, they annihilate, producing pure
energy. Okay so if there is equal amount - if
like every particle has its antimatter particle
twin doesn't that mean that everything would be
destroyed because all the antimatter's destroying
its partner matter? Yes it does and the fact that
it doesn't happen like that is a big problem for
physics. So you don't know? We don't know, this
is a big problem. And do we need antimatter?
Well it's a good job that there's none around
because we wouldn't be here but we do need it for
doing all sorts of things yeah. Well I gotta say I
am pretty glad that it isn't currently destroying
the entire universe. So even though it's a
physics mystery and it doesn't make sense to me,
I'm happy. Thanks Ciaran. All right. No worries.
So it goes like this, there is matter in
the world, subatomic particles, protons,
electrons, you know what they are and for every
particle there is its antimatter counterpart
and this is exactly the same except it has the
opposite charge. Now what happens when antimatter
meets matter is the two collide and they get
annihilated, disappear into a burst of energy.
However we're seeing less antimatter in the
universe than we are matter. Why is that? We
don't know. Physics doesn't know but hey look
I'm not gonna complain because it's probably a
good thing and the more that we can figure out
how to harness antimatter the more things we
could probably do with it. Maybe even one day
a Star Trek antimatter warp drive. That'd be
pretty cool. Hey there thanks for watching.
If you liked this video you can see more
Elevator Pitch here or you could subscribe
below for more videos from ABC Science and
if you're keen to uncover more cosmological
mysteries then stream Catalyst on ABC iview.